[Music]
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv vales contag
this world of entrepreneurs we get no
value to haters run homie look what I
become I'm I'm the
one what we're doing today this what it
is okay good morning good morning good
morning episode 318 home team today with
Tom Vinnie and Kayon uh we got a lot of
stories to cover apparently breaking
news a rumor has it Putin just had a
heart attack based on what they're
telling us Cardiac Arrest uh Kremlin
Cardiac Arrest we got a lot of other
stories to cover obviously some stuff
that's going on it's not slowing down
did you mention like I mean but Adam not
being here like had gender reassignment
surgery we don't want to talk she's a
he's going to come back as a strong
woman I wanted why' you want let him
make that
announcement let him make that it's a
she he already had the surgery f so
adamina ad let him make the announcement
you just ruined it I'm sorry you just
ruined you took my chair for the new guy
made me sit over
here just alike so you can't tell us
apart tweetle do you twe D Jerome Powell
is talking about interest rates we got
to go to Vinnie to give us an update on
that people are wondering if it's going
to move or not we're seeing 30-year
fixed mortgage rates right now 8% 8%
okay lowest ever home sales in decades
home sales in decades
least amount of refinance applications
mortgage applications coming in in 27
years 27 years and it ain't slowing down
Obama warns Israel strikes on Gaza could
backfire Elon musk's finances May crash
Tesla stock to the ground this is a New
York Post story uhoh car payment
defaults hits 29-year high as borrowing
costs surge forclosures continue to
Surge are they a threat to the housing
market New York Post story Argentino got
a runoff John Stewart show on Apple is
over because of disagreement about China
and AI we'll talk about that for sure
Americans have to pay 52% more to buy a
home compared to renting okay uh adult
kids are moving in with their parents to
save money for homes there's never been
a worst time to buy instead of rent Wall
Street Journal I know a lot of Realtors
don't like this article this is like
Realtors kind of skip through this you
know how you kind of going through
article no skip this is that one article
you don't want to read or you don't want
to but it's out there you want you may
want to read it as an insurance guy I
always read the articles I don't want to
read to see what's going on with the
industry when it was regulation this is
there's never been a worse time to buy
worst time remember you were asking us a
year and a half AG go wi us I kept
saying you said
1236 so ass Syrian W as well SP so what
you're saying is still way sp sp okay if
Victoria Secret returns to sexiness
after woke feminist campaign fails we
definitely have to talk about that thank
goodness the New York La time story this
by the way this is very surpris Rob can
you even pull up the picture of this LA
Times story I was very surprised to see
that LA Times would have written an
article like this kudos to them LA Times
said the left has really let us down why
many American Jews feel abandoned okay
the left Jews for longest time have been
on the left forever that's their party
but they say the left has let us down
fed warns that Hamas Hezbollah could be
Crossing the the southern border okay
associate prep AP will not let reporters
call Hamas a terrorist organization
imagine that the US the US government
categorically calls them Isis and
Hezbollah a terrorist organization but
AP will not let reporters call them that
wow New York Times admits a r too
heavily on Hamas Hospital claims um it's
always too late when the story comes out
Goldman Sachi housing starts next year
slumping to their lowest level since
early 1990s 33 years ago okay A
recession will hit next year this is an
Insider story hammering stock prices and
home values Wall Street veteran predicts
Amazon tells managers they can now fire
employees who won't work come to the
office three times a week okay can you
imagine hey minimum is now 20 three
times a week women 25 Sparks Fierce
debate after branding College as a scam
and new detail and Obama's death comes
out personal chef raised questions uh if
we have to add a couple other ones Jada
pinkit confirms she had sexual
experiences with wom before deciding I
love men what a what a as if she can't
disappear enough more and more stories
comes out selling something new and
we're guilty for bringing it up and some
stories came up about George Floyd So
before we go into these stories today
folks um I want to get into business and
before I do that I want to give a shout
out to somebody I'm give a shout out to
somebody
so uh Saturday night uh uh we had a
great time you and iul Jen ROM we went
spend time R what an amazing experience
phenomenal guy fantastic 60,000 foot
Castle all that stuff loved him for
those that don't know who he is he if
you can pull up Romero Britto so people
know who he is he's like a he's like the
modern famous artist from Brazil aming
and his work is everywhere his work has
been sold $4 billion worldwide I mean $4
billion four billion that's a lot of
money right there but then afterwards we
went to dinner at Prime I kind of want
to share this with everybody that's if
you're in business and you're wondering
about how to get uh um you know I had a
conversation with one of my friends the
other day we getting closer and closer
will G unreasonable Hospitality from 11
Madison he's the guy that took 11
Madison to the number one restaurant in
the world and I've recommended this book
unreasonable Hospitality to everybody MH
we're at Prime the other day 16 of us
we're having dinner Prime Steak in Miami
food's great Jan took us out
everything's good we're done we've been
there for 3 hours we want to leave I'm
outside I'm like babe where are you guys
where are you guys babe you won't
believe what's going on what's going on
babe you will not believe what's going
on babe tell me what is going on Mario
then calls me like what the hell is
going on inside oh you already trying to
you I'm trying to figure out what is
going on and then they said the waiter
not allowing us to pay the bill what
keep in mind this is a $3,000 Bill he's
not letting Jen pay the bill okay so Jen
is sitting there like uh uh calling me
saying what do I do with this I said
what do you mean what do I do mari's
like no he's not taking a credit card he
paid for it with his credit card the
waiter did the waiter phenomenal service
guy's name is Jesus Gonzalez uh stud of
a guy the way he gave a service I went
up to him talk to me was emotional
saying how much the contents Chang his
life but for me when I hear a story like
that and this guy's now real estate
agent would Compass so I want to give
him a shout out if you are in the Miami
Coral Gables Coconut Grove area and
you're thinking about buying a property
Rob let's put his number down we got
permission to put his info at the bottom
okay I'm going to text you this I want
you to put this in the chat this is
what's called unreasonable hospitality
and not expecting anything in return he
didn't ask us to do this I'm doing this
we got permission to share his
information whether it's giving him love
for what he just did on Saturday night
and he's in tears telling me this how
much contact that's his contact
information put the link below for
anybody I wants to find if you want to
help someone their career get off the
ground he's been in Hospitality he was
an amazing amazing you know gave us
amazing service on my birthday such a
phenomenal service that he gave me give
this man a shot worst case scenario send
him a text give him some love what a got
a shout out so proud of him and I love
hearing stories like this uh uh when
people take their game to the next level
he didn't have to do this $3,000 is a
lot of money to pay for dinner I was
just going to say so just really fast so
he he served you guys you guys and then
his his his thing was because he's watch
your content and you've helped him get
to the next level that he like value
tment content is what he says change my
life wow okay that's I love I love
people like this because they have the
fabric of what Val the what value tment
stands for the values principles of what
we've talked about for the last 10 years
that's what got this guy to uh uh do
what he did respect you Jesus give this
man some love if you want to do business
you're trying to buy a house or do
something contact Asus Gonzalez now now
is not a great time to buy a house but
in six months to a year he's going to be
regardless regardless this is a guy
regardless this is a guy you may want to
stay close to okay so let's go through a
couple different things that we got
going on right now I want to start off
with John Stewart's show John Stewart
this is a CNN story John Stewart's show
on Apple is over because of disagre
agreements over China now this is a CNN
story folks this is not a uh uh uh any
other story but it's a CNN story John
Stewart's show on Apple is over because
of disagreements about China uh his show
the problem with JN Stewart on Apple TV
will not return for third season with
John Stewart and apple Executives
agreeing to part ways uh Stewart
disclosed that apple had reservations
about topics he planned to address in
the upcoming season including China
Israel and artificial int intelligence
telling his staff the company had
concerns about the the subject matter
despite initially granting Stewart's
creative control over the show tensions
mounted as Apple began to exert
influence over guest choices and show
content steuart Express his frustration
to his staff stating Apple was pushing
back on the show's guest list and show
subjects the cancellation raises
questions about the impact of Apple's
extensive business interest in China
which accounts for nearly a fifth of the
company sales and its fastest growing
region Tom when you read this article
what do you think about here's what I
think so you know Apple's trying to sell
more stuff and the more stuff they're
trying to sell now they you the Apple
watch has popped up and what have they
introduced lately that's really popped
up they the vision Vision headsets they
really haven't really haven't started
yet so they're trying to sell more stuff
and Apple TV is what they're trying to
sell and they sell more Apple TV they
want unique stuff so they went out and
overpaid John Stewart to be there that
was the formula so step one overpay for
Talent on Apple TV you know what they
paid him do you know his contract uh no
not off hand okay keep going I'll look
for it Rob if you can keep looking for
it but you it it was big when you take a
look at where he was or where he was
going in Apple TV so step one overpay
for talent such as John Stewart step two
dive under your desk as he starts
talking about AI being bad China being
bad sir that's our largest manufacturing
base sir that's um also the market we're
trying to break into he said it again
sir what do we do step three fire his
ass step four dive under your desk again
as he starts talking to the New York
Times and New York Post and other things
about what's going on and so you know if
you're Apple you need to understand that
if you're not a media company and you're
not set up to do this then you can't do
this because you know everything from
freedom of speech to comedians are going
to be comedians to to John Stewart had a
wide political lens that he had woven
into his comedy and so what do I see
here Pat I see here a
manufacturer the first3 trillion market
cap company in history trying to find
new revenue streams and when they get
into programming in a media company
they're finding they get hamstrung by
all these collisions how much did Apple
lose in the last four weeks Tom how much
valuation has Apple lost in the last
four weeks you told me this yesterday y
320 to 360 billion of market cap loss in
in by the way I don't know if you heard
that how much did you say Tom 320 to
$360 billion of total company value and
um Rob find out what the value of
Snapchat is right now mhm real quick
while we're looking that up you know the
thing 15.4 billion how many Snapchats
did Apple lose in the course of the last
two months 20 20 24 Snapchats they lost
in the last four weeks that's exactly
right they lost 24 Snapchats in the last
four weeks go for G on well I was
thinking that that John Stewart his his
model is like 10 years old and and then
Apple's trying to enter this game with a
like an old horse that's kind of hasn't
been doing the daily shows numbers have
gone down so they're betting on
something whereas what we're doing here
podcast like this you can't just throw
money at it and it works you have to
have something that's interesting and
you have to be willing to take those
slings and arrows I see you getting
everyone in this room gets hate from
both sides of the fence whenever we talk
about a subject you have to be ready for
that fight and apple is not ready for
that I will tell you though John Stewart
I thought his show I think Bill Mah went
to a whole different level during coid
and John missed the mark because John
joined the other camp
until John went on coar and it's like
hey why are we not considering the fact
that the virus could be coming from
Wuhan lab I mean and he stood up and he
did that whole act I don't know if you
remember that or not that was great and
then everybody's like whoa okay that's
where you are John so for for John to
now want to talk Israel China AI okay so
look at Apple three things they're
concerned about China China I I think
Apple sells more iPhones than China than
they do in us if I'm not mistaken I
think China has 24% of market share of
China and 21% here can you look up the
numbers whatever the market share
percentages are on how many I I may be
wrong with the 24 and 21 they've been
climbing in China but China recently
said their government employees can no
longer use an iPhone they're worried
about it Tim Cook is trying to kind of
Juggle this the transition from making
phones in China to India I'm sure China
knows it's public information now so
it's not like China sitting there behind
closed door saying look this guy's not
on our side if they could take their
phones out of here they would do it on a
heartbeat so I they're going to put
iPhone over uh uh what do you call it
John Stewart of course they're going to
put uh iPhone over they got to protect
China over John AI they're doing over
John Israel kind of you got to be
careful because you don't want enemies
everybody's your customer but uh is JN
gonna find another job is John G to do
another thing here's what I love to see
John
do what if John decides to go
independent John says you know what I'm
just going to do it my way I'm just
going to go do it my own way you know
kind of like Tucker's been doing it
recently how about if I go do my own
thing that I'm doing here if he does or
he doesn't I think he's got the talent
to be able to do it will he go to the
Bill Mar Direction I don't know I still
think John Stewart's a necessary vote I
I first of all P because I don't see
100% eye to eye with him those moments
on that show I gained some respect I got
respect for him too cuz Kon you know
this as a as a content creator when you
have creative control Pat that means I
get to put whatever I want on the fact
that they're like Hey listen China you
can't and then you know he said no and
he's probably out I respect him but this
watching and reading this Pat I it shows
how much power and control China has
this let's just do a quick history no
accountability for coid uh they're
moving warships closer to the United
States they're buying land next to our
military installations they have spy
balloons flying across the country uh
and and that just goes to show you how
much of a threat Trump was to them
because he was trying to hold them
accountable and then think about this P
even if you talk bad about China
remember John Cena said something about
Taiwan or something he came out and
spoke INF fluent Mandarin and was like
I'm sorry and powing down to these
people and it's like that just goes to
show you how much control and how much
power China has well over us China send
students our way China has a Tik Tok for
us they won't even let their own people
on that version of TI Tok figure that so
check this out I want I want to I want
to share this here Rob can you pull up
this link I just found market share of
iPhones worldwide this is very important
to see because here we go their iPhone
15 I got the iPhone 15 right here how is
it uh and I didn't upgrade last year
because the only reason I don't upgrade
is so annoying every time you have to
redo all your passwords and I have like
so many different passwords so very the
transition is still very annoying when
you're going from phone to phone it's
still not as smooth your trans phone I
got it it's not a anti so I'm anti-trans
transitioning from an iPhone 13 to 15
although it was very handy yesterday it
gets so hot we actually made ramen
noodles with it watch this go a little
lower go a little lower where allows you
to see all the countries go a little
lower I was just on it keep going keep
going right there okay so North Korea
market share wow what it's kind of weird
right wait a minute Android market in
North Korea is 0.5% but kill it Apple
has 99.5% of North Korea did you even
know this the j- did not know this North
Korea only 17 people are allowed to have
so that's a good point Monaco 69 keep
going us is like at 56% go lower lower
lower us is where right 56 and 12% 5
okay but watch this and then Android is
43% I did not know 43% of Americans use
Android honestly I had no clue 43% can
you run a quick poll to see if our
audience is more Android or iPhone I'm
actually curious and if you go lower you
know where China's at China is at 24% go
go go lower 20 it should be around 24
right there
24.3% by the way that's 24.3 on 1.5
billion right dude that's a lot that's
that's America okay so think about
24.3% right Android's at 753 so
Android's crushing iPhone in China China
that's crazy 75% and they're not putting
Huawei and some Huawei is mainly Android
but
25% 1.5 billion is still
375 million America has at 50% so they
got 150 million customers here for you
know uh what do you call it 375 milon of
course you have to be protect 110%
market share in America with that number
right you know what's crazy and I'm I'm
this may sound strange I actually like
Tim Cook as a CEO I think Tim Cook is a
decent CEO and I would put better than a
decent CEO this guy took a company when
Steve Jobs died at100 billion he took it
from $100 billion to3 trillion lost 350
billion last four weeks yeah but he's I
think he's done a decent job I think
he's trying to balance something that's
going to be juggle something that's
going to be very hard transitioning out
out out of China to go to India that's
not easy to do that's right and you know
what I think that's probably what the
problem is with the iPhone 15 it's the
overheating it's the
curry Cur comes out in a
hurry which by the way I love curry I've
been to Mumbai I ate at the same place
every day for five straight days when we
were in Mumbai shout out to the curry
really quick question though so there's
problem with the overheating is that
something that you guys are going to
have to return your phones and get new
ones cuz that's a major issue I don't
know if they've ever done a recall I
don't think it's like cars to do a
recall but if you remember what happened
a few years ago when Apple took off
Android took a lead on Apple yeah when
all of the biggest advertisement Apple
ever got where it took their business to
a complete different level with market
cap exploding is when Android started
exploding and on flights the flight
attendant would say uh if you have a
Android Galaxy dut It Off please shut it
off because of what's been happening
recently Apple ran with that their whole
campaign was you can a trusted phone
that doesn't explode right yeah so
terrorists love
Android if this thing the
official this is fun the bom yeah
literally and fig all right so funny but
not funny but the time I what you're
saying Apple's not going anywhere 2.7
trillion dollar company not going
anywhere but it just goes to show you if
you're going to get into the media and
you're going to give your talent
creative control that means you have no
creative control less learned I I think
there like I'll have a conversation with
Vinnie and our creative control is my
dad by the way with Vinnie y he runs the
shop when it comes on to creative
control he'll sit with Vinnie and say
Vinnie come here come here not at church
too he'll bring me in church that's
outside I think there's levels to
creative control but to say you can't
talk about this you can't talk about
that after you negotiated that you would
M that's a problem okay so let's go to
the next one Victoria Secret returns to
sexiness after woke feminine campaign
fails Victoria Secret is abandoning its
woke marketing approach and returning to
its hypersexualized image after nearly 3
years of falling sales according to
president Greg Unice the brand is focus
refocusing on sexiness interesting I
wonder why while claiming it can be it
can it can celebrate the diverse
experience of our customers rebranding
effort which began in 2019 with the
suspension of the famous Angels Runway
shows and continued in 2021 with the
introduction of the vs collo Collective
including figures like Megan can you can
you pull up actually Google the vs
Collective and go to images see what
comes up including figures like Megan
Reno has not been successful CEO Martin
Waters admitted that despite best
efforts it has not been enough to carry
to day to recover from projected Revenue
decreases including a 5% drop in 2023
compared to the previous year Victoria
Secret is resuming Runway shows
relaunching swimwear and and active wear
lines and modernizing its physical store
Kon what do you have on this story what
are your thoughts on this this just
proves that being woke doesn't work for
so many things and how do you mess up
TNA like we already love it you have to
go out of your way and it's not just the
Megan rapino scientific right that's
kind of science it science got to trust
the science they went and made 300 lb
mannequins you're trying to sell women
and men on the fantasy of lingerie yes
these people exist but you're selling
the fantasy so you got 300b mannequin
they told me I can't use my plastic
straw and my smoothie and they're making
they're using all the straw plas to make
the bigger mannequins I I call them
manatees and they fire they need to fire
all of their experts because you look at
it there is a uh there's the stock
market which has gone down 5% for them
but there's the appendage Market you
don't need an expert you just see if if
if the man looks at the outfit and it
goes like that that's going to do well
and if it that's not going to wow what
what an angle you took now that you have
to be able to have technology to see
through clothes to see what it's what
it's doing but Vinnie what would you say
to this that's I'm furious as somebody
that's been analyzing their content for
many years Victor secret watch I'm
actually Furious Pat the I'm I love like
that big huge like I cuz some of the
runways I guess broke like I'm in like I
don't know why they're changing it back
the runway broke the runways and like I
just feel like the runway became a
halfpipe like nothing turns me on more
than looking at somebody I'm like wow
that's that's morbidly obese person by
the way do you have friends be honest do
you have friends that like big girls
100% too Patrick are they what can I ask
you question I had a roommate can I ask
the ethnicity are they Middle Eastern
are they black I'm not even going to
tell you my guy is Middle Eastern and
he's a goodlooking handsome guy and he's
like I have I have friends who like big
girls yeah and they're across the board
now most of the time when people will
say guy that likes big girls they're
also big or they're not handsome or
something like that but believe it or
not there were some very good-looking
guys that preferred big girls okay now
to each's own yeah one liked super super
big girls okay uh where it was just a
and by the way he was my roommate in the
Army so you the see girls see here are
you kidding me like I was like I would
say it's 2:00 in the morning buddy take
a break but oh no look you know you know
what's the best thing about what's going
on with Victoria Secret
okay uh Victoria's Secret was a good buy
3 months ago somebody should have bought
Victoria's Secret 3 months ago m Maxim
just came out with another woke thing
did you see about what Maxim just came
out with Maxum mag just type in Maxim
magazine woke and and you'll see if you
type in Maxim magazine woke uh zoom in a
little bit zoom in a little bit why
Maxim uh uh go ahead go ah in the top
100 right the top 100 hottest people uh
you know who's in there Margo Robbie's
in there but you know who else is in
there a trans man is in their top 100
hot list transgender woman is the top
100 hot list by the way Maxim magazine
is a great buy do you remember when
Maxim magazine used to be 300 pages with
high quality content was sick they were
selling sex they were selling it to the
young 24 25y old 30-year-old you know
going out there lifestyle it was like
one of those magazines everybody wanted
to buy and then all of a sudden boom
they go woke okay so Victoria's Secret
I'm glad by the way that's one of the
top 100 best looking women in the world
wait wait wait wait no no that's
according to Maxim you swear bro go up
go show the content at the top Rob so
they can see it
wait that's before and after he is 92 of
the top 100 hottest women in the world
according to Maxim magazine in Australia
look at that how do we get look at that
that that's the point but here's the
part you know what's the best thing
about these time these types of dumb
ideas it takes a year two years three
years to get exposed it's exactly what's
going on with Victoria Secret time for
somebody that's on their Elite Victoria
Secret Chopper what would you say about
what Victoria Secret is doing the change
yes my name is Bill Clinton and I
approved this message so bill is back
and here's my question though when when
you know what I think it is no I'll give
you honestly from an entrepreneur just a
management standpoint they let
themselves be swayed by the mob not by
the data that they knew about their
products not but what they understood
they let themselves be swayed by the mob
and they just took an economic holiday
that is actually left to use the bisoc
phrase that has left them work than they
found them that left their own finances
worse than they found them so there's
the consequence you bow to the Mob you
don't do what's right for your customer
and you're going to wake up one day that
mob isn't going to help you move your
stock price back up that mob doesn't
care about the losses you got that mob
doesn't care what you're enduring
they're just going to go out and try to
intimidate the next one and that's what
I think but P but here's my question Pat
you're a CEO you own multiple companies
PHP hu huge company I I don't understand
how like they allow this woke like for
instance Bud Light did the Dylan Mulaney
billions of dollars right target they
were going after you know the kids
sexualized and killed budl supposedly
was wasn't topped down supposedly it
wasn't topped down it was the
independent Marketing Group that was for
budl they had their VP levels they had
Authority and they took this step and
they stepped in it but what Tom my point
is I I don't know about that Tom Tom
somebody let let me give you let me give
you my my think here everything Rises
and falls on the leader okay so as much
as you and I met him we had a
conversation with him the CEO was a
former CIA agent former Marine y stud of
a guy went to Harvard smart guy smart
guy had a very good conversation with
him and I told him to his face when I
spoke to him how do you not know a
marketing campaign like that you do and
you mean to tell me you Empower
everybody to make those decisions
without running that big of a campaign
that controversial campaign through you
I'm sorry if you didn't know about that
then you're not fit to run a company
that big exactly you have to have
leaders that know these are the things
that are the no- goes when it come for
example you know what I would do here's
what I would do so for ex I would take
the angle of saying that you know how uh
when we first raiseed our Capital the
first capital we raised no the second
one $10 million we raised hey anytime
you uh are making any kind of decisions
above a half a million dollars guess
what what you guys have to know give us
a call yep okay so what do we do we
never called them well tell them what
that meant tell them what that meant you
didn't hear what I just said Tom no I
did no you did not hear what I said of
course they know what it means it means
every time you're making a purchase over
half a million give us a call to confirm
so of course we call them every single
time we get we have we'd have that
friendly conversation well most of the
time but but here's the part the point
is we would call and we would say hey
we're going to do this it's going to
cost 2 million bucks okay tell us the
number okay great we're going to do the
$600,000 great no problem so if a person
is running a company that big you would
say any marketing campaign that is
public branding us has to be seen and
approved
by these four seite Executives I would
choose two that are from the left two
that are from the right that's how I
would do it and I would say look these
guys are this side give your opinion
these guys are this side we would have a
board and an environment that encourages
debate okay where you guys can hash it
out and argue with each other and say
here's what I think's a good idea here's
what I think's a bad idea no problem and
then if it's a big campaign that you're
doing something that's controversial
having to be tied to Israel Middle East
Wars LG btq anything like that I must
approve okay so I'm not convinced
anheiser Bush didn't know about it and
they just kind of went through it and if
they didn't I think it's mismanagement
of something like that that cost them
$30 billion but go ahead finish your
thought I'm just curious It's still
costing it has not bounce back I'm just
curious Pat because when is the left
going to realize your woke doesn't
work from from the Bud Light from the
target to defund the police they're
batting over for a thousand it's like at
what point uh Pat are they going to go
okay guys no I don't even want to hear
any of your stupid they're not
winning at all zero wins not even a hit
on base this isn't their playing field
they don't care they're not trying to
win here but but trust me Common Sense
always prevails but before Common Sense
prevails a lot of people get destroyed
this isn't anything new how many how
many people do you know like you know
I've seen guys that would have been
Giants with us in sales in the insurance
industry or even here they would have
been Giants okay
they chose a short-term girl over their
career I've seen girls that would have
been incredible they chose a short-term
six-month Flink thinking he loved her
but it was just a fling he wanted just
one thing and then she fell in love
ruined her career and eventually three
four five years later they said I was
wrong and Common Sense prevails but it
that guy stole five years of his life
that guy five years of her life or you
know she stole 5 years of his life this
happens we've been guilty of falling for
this trap many times so common sense
prevails but I want to go to this other
story that has to do with this okay we
live in the great state of what Florida
right Ronda Sanz okay has done a
phenomenal job but obviously he's being
targeted so watch what's happening with
Florida insurance premium that everybody
is talking about Rob if you can pull up
the logo at the top so we can see it's
Newsweek so this is a Newsweek zoom in a
little bit more so they can see it there
you go Newsweek magazine Florida
residents flee State as insurance
premiums Skyrocket up to
900% this is a topic of discussion
across the country a lot of people right
now are trashing and bashing Florida and
the santis let's go a little bit lower
on the numbers okay so for years now the
sunny vibrant State of Florida magnetic
destination for many Americans a
phenomenon which has been driving up
demand for housing especially during the
pandemic as well as home prices but
while Florida was the number one state
in the country that people moved to in
2022 it was also the number one with the
highest number of residents wanting to
relocate according to Self Storage
according to the US Census Bureau an
estimated 275,000 people left Florida in
2022 nearly 23,000 people every month
most according to the be relocated to
places like Georgia 47,000 North
Carolina 42,000 tennessy 36,000 South
Carolina 31,000 Texas 30,000 somebody
would read this article say oh my God
Florida's losing it all go L go Lord the
part about 27 $1,700 versus 4 right
there homeowners insurance premium have
tripled in state of a uh in the past 5
years with residents currently paying on
average of $4,200 per year the national
average is $1,700 by the way this is an
accurate number that they're talking
about some insurance premiums have risen
about nine times what they were in 2022
Oscar chief executive of NSI Insurance
told W wsa Wall Street Journal with
multi-million dollar homes generating
premiums costing as much as $600,000 a
year I know on what these numbers are
because I'm kind of going through this
however here's what I want you to do if
you go to the top where it says how many
people have have
left the state of uh uh uh what do you
call it the State of Florida when you
read that article what is your immediate
reaction what do you say you say what oh
my God oh my gosh I'm being spun 23,000
people are leaving Florida I thought
they were moving to Florida terrible I
guess the other news was wrong yeah and
then and then you actually go to the US
Census Bureau to verify see this number
and then this is what US Census Bureau
says Rob I just texted
fact check pull this up no but the part
is that media not telling the entire
information confuses people okay totally
confuses people this article is telling
you oh Florida's like California now
people are leaving Florida people are
leaving Florida pull up the pull up the
article I just sent you Rob if you could
uh uh it's in the link this is by the
way the level of manipulation on how
they're targeting the r listen I call
that Ronda santis a lot I'm not sitting
here saying I'm a you know 100%
supportive of everything he does their
Camp probably wouldn't look at pbd
podcast as a pro Ronda santis Camp No
but here when you're targeting a guy
that's done a phenomenal job for a state
the entire story needs to be told go all
the way to the bottom to look okay the
domestic net migration by state that's
the number the number you're looking for
is what net migration go all the way to
the down that it gives you the plus
minus keep right there right there
that's the number look at this three the
number one state in 2022 net migration
is what 38
855 you know what this means you know
the number Newsweek says it's 275 yeah
that means if 275 left you know how many
came here's what this means it's called
275 plus 318 here we go 600,000 here we
comes
593 th000 moved here that's 50k a month
but 23 chose to leave the net is 318
that's why you always look at the
domestic net migration what's number two
by a mile another great State Texas 231
then it's the Carolinas then Tennessee
Georgia Arizona Idaho what do you notice
there red states are attracting people
now go to the bottom who do you think's
all the way at the bottom by the way go
all the way to the bottom all the way to
the bottom California minus
343 holy minus 3 then it's two New
York then it's two Illinois then it's
two Jersey then it's to Massachusetts
blue blue blue blue blue by the way New
York where the Newsweek is located what
you and I have in common Tom let me tell
you what you and I have in common I want
you to think about if a man
okay had the
privilege okay the satisfaction of
having been with Marilyn Monroe
Elizabeth Taylor and Sophia luren he can
expand and speak on their different
styles of course in the bedroom yes
Marilyn Monroe was like this sop Yen
liked the pillow like this you know
Elizabeth Taylor liked XYZ toys what if
he can kind of expand on that right all
right so check this out I lived in
California for 20 20 something years I
lived in Texas for five plus years I've
been in Florida now nearly 3 years
January it'll be three years that we've
been here so I know California I know
New York I know Texas Texas phenomenal
place to raise a family to have your
business it's an incredible Place some
of the places they're trying to turn
blue Austin's getting blue the
homelessness problem in Austin's a real
problem California is still a
okay people are leaving companies are
leaving parents are leaving they're sick
of what's going on in California and
when you look at the great state of
Florida what do they keep doing they
keep attracting they keep standing up do
you know what the the stist just said he
said if Biden chooses to take refugees
from Gaza he says you know how many
people can come to Florida this is how
many we're going to take this is how
many we're going to take if that offends
you Florida's not the state for you I
highly recomend commend you go to
California when these people are sitting
there saying I feel uncomfortable my kid
not being able to transition in the in
the State of Florida you know what I
tell them California is a great spot for
you beautiful keep going there and and
remember when we were in California I
don't know if you you were with us right
we went to to the debate did you go you
didn't go to Ral I wasn't Cali we had a
big debate at Yoshinoya with this one
guy that pulled up to me saying I love
your content the only thing I don't like
about you is the fact that you bash
California we had a 30-minute I said sit
down let's have a conversation at 11:30
at Yoshinoya okay that we're having this
don't ask us why we go to I secretly
love yo yes takes me back to being 14
WIS great yeah what's what's the moral
of the story here's the moral of the
story when people show you numbers and
data unpack the numbers to see really
what's going on when I saw this numbers
you know what I noticed watch what
happened to here you know what insurance
company just left the state of Florida
what insurance company just announced
they're leaving the State of Florida a
company called Farmers what they left
the state of Florida so now everybody's
saying Farmers left the state of Florida
yeah they also don't do business in
Hawaii in Maine in New Hampshire any of
the what do you call it co and even in
California they're regulated right but
this article no one looks up and sees
what other places Farmers left they left
this and here's what people don't
realize you know who's the first person
that signed the UN agreement to make
more companies follow the ESG
environmental social governance you know
who was the first company that signed it
who it was Farmers Oh weird and you know
what jimy petronis Farmers the Bud Light
of insurance they're about to be the Bud
Light of insurance and heer Bush of
insurance by the way the reason why I
would I didn't even have plans of going
into this story when you guys talk about
Victoria's Secret automatically I saw
what's going on here in the State of
Florida I thought we had to talk about
it Tom do you have any any thoughts on
what's going on here with Florida wow
Farmers so it's we are
leaving right no it's it's it's very
simple Jimmy petronus is right and Jimmy
Patronus by the way he is the basically
the CFO of the State of Florida and he
is responsible for economic forecast
into making it attractive environment
understanding regulation because you
know we have property taxes here we have
things you got to pay for fire trucks
and police somehow and we don't have a
state income tax and so he is out there
basically just putting companies on
notice that if you guess what if you
want to come here and you want to want
to play right guess what I got a great
economy for you I got a lot of people
here and you can do what you want you
want to go be a little bit weird and
then you want to get mad and leave take
your marbles and go home because there
are other people here that want to serve
the people of Florida there you go okay
Rob do you have any kind of the poll
that we asked earlier about how many of
our guys use Android versus iPhone I'm
actually curious right now how many
people did the poll yes so uh I ended
the poll after we stopped uh talking
about that but we had
2200 votes 50% of the audience uses
Android 49% uses iPhone wow you know
what I'm actually very impressed by that
the fact that the how diverse and how
close it is between the two because if
you look look what do you use rap are
you an Android or an iPhone iPhone yeah
are your iPhone your iPhone I'm you have
to to work here I don't like those green
bubbles the green right the Green's a
problem in our interview process we say
are you green or blue excuse me iPhone
or Droid can't do it here with Droid
right anyways okay that's good to know
about the audience all right next story
to go to let's talk about what's going
on with real estate okay so to all our
friendly real estate folks out there you
may want to skip this next part or just
listen up on what's going on because
I've asked many of my my friends who are
in the business that are willing to be
reasonable and give Insight on what's
going on they're telling me uh it's
going to be a rough 2024 but maybe we're
wrong okay there's never been a worse
time to buy instead of rent this is the
title to the Wall Street Journal article
on October 19th the cost of buying a
home versus renting has reached an
extreme level with the average monthly
new mortgage payments being 52% higher
than apartment rent 52% high that means
if the mortgage payment is
$33,000 the rent payment is give or take
$22,000 okay that's the widest Gap since
at least 1996 again 27 years we're
talking about factors contributing to
this imbalance include surging debt cost
as 30-year mortgage rates reach 8% and
housing prices driven by increased
demand for domestic space during the
pandemic Rising house prices make it
challenging for renters to afford down
payments and while they collapse in
prices could restore balance it's
unlikely in the absence of a major
recession the over Supply to rental
homes weak 10 in demands and low vacancy
rates are also impacting landlords and
in institutional investors in the US
housing market Tom so this is not a
surprise so the interest rates go up and
when interest rates go up mortgage rates
go up so now it's more expensive for
your payment for the same siiz house you
know if you bought the the same size
house you know last year this year your
mortgage payments going to be be much
higher we've talked about that we've
shown how these 8% rates have
effectively doubled the mortgage payment
so now it's expensive payment the other
thing is is when there's a limited
Supply like when there's only nine
Mickey manle cards and only two of them
are perfect PS they're perfect PSA 99's
those cards are million-dollar cards
it's because of scarcity and what we
have right now we don't have a lot of um
houses on the market for sale and uh can
they see the chart Rob can the folks see
the chart there it is so starting in
2011 2011 it was right after the crash
so you see the peak
there 2006 housing was very expensive it
was uh very expensive to buy versus rent
then you had the big short and
everything we know about that 2008 whmo
and all of a sudden hey 2011 I could buy
a house and that went on for almost 10
years where it was sort of neutral if
you could save a down payment you had a
reasonable mortgage see there but then
when coid happened and the inflation
went up then they raised the interest
rates and a lot of people were like hey
you know what if we move to Florida hey
Kim if we move to Florida to retire you
know let's just Airbnb our house one of
the kids says they could Airbnb the
house we got a 3% mortgage here in
Philadelphia let's just Airbnb the house
do you want to sell it no no no no no
let's not sell it let's let's just keep
it and guess what that's what's going on
people are keeping the low mortgage
houses they have so if there's fewer
houses for sale it's just like when
there's only 10 manal cards and
everybody wants it the price goes up so
now the homes are way too high if you
could put together a down payment great
job got a Bonus found something you
could afford your payment's going to be
high you're going to even good credit
you're going to be a 7 half% mortgage so
that's what's going right now so with
payments high and housing prices High
there's the graph there's never been a
worse time to buy a house so moral story
for the value tment audience don't feel
bad don't beat yourself up save your
dollars save your money the situation
will eventually turn around see that
chart the situation goes in Cycles it
may take a while find someplace great to
rent it rents may not be cheap you may
have to to work it you may have to be
you know very opport move with your
parents your par some of these stories
that we're that's going up because you
know what you know interest rates are do
we have the interest rate chart do we
have that old yeah this is sort of the
Victoria's Secret stock chart and the um
interest rate chart all built into one I
thought Rob had it here and it was there
it is it's the pickle chart wow so you
can think of this as interest rates
going up or um Victoria's Secret stock
now that they've brought the good girls
back so we bring back the pickle chart
it's not it's not slowing down when
you're looking at this but here's the
thing okay so last year I made a video
about real estate taking a hit I got a
lot of heat a lot of people from the
real estate market St Pat you don't know
what you're talking about you know all
this stuff about real estate I'm willing
to hear these guys out they've been the
business for for 10 20 years I haven't
gone on a podcast with Tom Ferry and we
we had a conversation with him and his P
buddy about you know what's going on
with real estate but the main thing they
talked about is look at foreclosures cuz
during Co there was a foreclosure bump
but it's because they suspended
foreclosures for a couple years and you
know they weren't letting that happen so
it wasn't real bump of foreclosures
however here's New York Post
foreclosures continue to Surge this is
not a good sign for Real Estate are they
a threat to the housing market
foreclosures notice a surge in third
quarter with 34% increase from the
previous year reaching nearly 125,000
homeowners this represents a 28% rise
from the previous quarter about one in
every 1121 properties faced foreclosure
filings in the third quarter not a big
number reflecting the expiration of
pandemic related moratorium so they're
kind of like relying on moratoriums to
not get kicked out be able to stay there
they were protected while Rising
foreclosures and home
prices uh high home prices May raise
concern of a repeat of 2008 crisis
experts believe a foreclosure crisis is
unlikely risky mortgages which sharp
payment increases have largely
disappeared lenders have tightened
qualification standards and there is a
currently high demand for homes this is
uh true because in 2008 people bought a
pick a payment loan or the neg
amortization loan or whatever you want
there's a bunch of different names for
it and most people were paying the
minimum you had four options minimum
interest only 30-year 15 year payment
15year payment was the highest minimum
you're paying less than interest so your
loan amount would get bigger and bigger
and bigger it was negative amortization
those guys when the two years came up or
the three years came up or the five five
years came up your payment went from
$1,920 to $4,200 people can't afford to
pay byy that because they locked you in
the fun time was over you had a real
payment the whole concept was buy it on
neam dude you'll set in three years and
make $200,000 of equity but it backfired
this is not the situation because we
don't have a lot of neam payments today
it's a lot of 30-year fixed payments or
10year interest only we don't have a lot
of that me so this thing is partially
true foreclosure foreclosure rates vary
across States and metropolitan areas
with New Jersey having the highest state
rate following South Carolina Delaware
Nevada and Maryland Tom when you see
foreclosure I want to get your thoughts
on that and two your thoughts on what
Jerome Pal's talking about with interest
rates what are you expecting to happen
with interest rates so two things so
first of all we'll talk about
foreclosures really quick and then we'll
get to a forecast with Jan pal so
foreclosures right now this is affecting
a lot of subprime lenders and also by
the way four of those five top states
are blue blue policies I mean let's take
a look at what's going there and so
there's a lot of things that are
interrelated here when you have what
we've had two and a half years of bad
inflation with one and a half of those
years being really bad remember
inflation is down but that doesn't mean
all the prices of everything returned
people you know gas may be down in
certain areas but it's still four or
five bucks higher what it was you you go
to the uh grocery store and they tell
you that inflation is backed down yeah
but that grocery cart pricing hasn't
come back down maybe eggs came back down
off their Spike so people have been
pinched who the basic Americans and they
call that subprime I wish there was
another word for it because it's almost
insulting it just means people that
don't have the highest credit and don't
have the greatest economic capability so
in other words the people that could ill
afford to be hit by inflation and buy a
tough economy and job market that's
starting to show up with some layoffs
now guess what those are the people with
subprime mortgage that were living on
the edge and what do you think happened
it doesn't have to be Florida they if
they the house has gone up property
taxes adjust in many jurisdictions
sometimes property taxes don't adjust to
you buy and sell a house sometimes they
adjust up and the homeowners insurance
comes up and the cost of overall
ownership and inflation and suddenly
those people find wow guess what I can't
make I can't make the payment and so now
the subprimes head toward foreclosures
driven by biomics and the economy and
that is what what has happened to these
people we'll get to Jo par in a second I
want I want to ask both of you guys so
tell is there going to be a breaking
point I know um John uh Michael bur P
he's predicted he's bet against it do
you guys feel that it's it's something
that's inevitably going to happen and
this Administration p is hanging on for
as long as they can so it doesn't happen
during their Administration scenario you
know uh I'm having this conversation
with Brandon and you know Brandon is
bisoc on unusual suspects steroids cuz
he looks like one of the smartest guys
I'm sorry I forgot about his biceps yeah
he's got to do double bound on next one
I love the shirt he wore on the last
episode but let me let me kind of talk
about this whole thing you're talking
about with uh with uh market crash okay
uh with uh uh whether it's going to
eventually backfire something happen got
you know what's worse than a market
crash what a a market crashing up you
know what happens when a market crashes
up like Venezuela did no here's what it
means okay do you know oh my God you
know where I'm going with this so these
guys printed trillions of dollars into
the economy that money's in the economy
printed Pat you said printed no no that
money is in the economy they fed the
economy trillions of dollars okay so
that money goes where Whoever has the
most value to be shown that's where the
money flows the money doesn't stay with
a person that doesn't know how to manage
if you don't have value the money goes
away to somebody else okay a reverse
market crash what happened do you know
what would happen if right now Jerome
Powell decreased rates to 6% 5% 4% 3% do
you know what would happen today you
think that house that's $900,000 that
the value hasn't moved even when they
raised the rates to 8% that $900,000
house is going to be 1 .4 million if it
goes to $1.4 million and DOW Jones all
of a sudden goes to
48,000 you know what just happened this
whole concept of Rich getting richer
poor getting poor it became Rich getting
richer poor getting poor on steroids the
separation between the two gets wider
and wider the Gap take the poor Middle
America's always been like this then you
have the rich top 1% whatever the
percentage is you're going to see The
Gap go like voom voom voom mhm did you
understand what I mean like the this is
going to get bigger the top rich is
going to get bigger The Middle's going
to come lower but the poor is going to
get bigger how the hell are you going to
if you can't afford a $900,000 house
right
now how you going to afford it in a year
if it if they lower the interest rates
to go to 3 four 5% some of these
realtors that are being irresponsible
just telling everybody well wait till
the rates come down if the rates come
down it's reverse market crash you want
that to happen to Venezuela what
happened to Venezuela to happen it'll
never happen you're just fear porn all
this stuff really people can't afford to
buy a house right now there's a reason
why they're renting you're not going to
have a customer qualifying for the $1.3
million home yes you have equity in your
house but even if you got equity in your
house you got to find a buyer buyer
can't afford it there's a reason why we
have so many strikes going on in America
right now people are saying I can't
afford my life I can't afford a $900,000
loan how the hell am I supposed to buy
$900,000 $600,000 house so to me when
you're saying is eventually going
to hit the fan essentially is what
you're asking for
the the the the amount the hard the
amount of hate and pressure Jerome
Powell has right now for taking the
rates where he's at uh he would have
taken it higher you're going to give an
update on the rate here that he would
have gone up another quarter of a point
of whatever that is uh by the way do we
have is this uh okay check this out
here's the Venezuela's uh reverse market
crash no one in the right mind thinks
that Rob I just texted it to you no one
in the right mind there's anybody think
that Venezuela has a great economy does
anybody think Venezuela has a great
economy does anybody say oh Venezuela
their Market is freaking amazing stock
market da d d da pull this up real quick
and show show what happened to
Venezuela's market right there okay
stock market this is what you call a
reverse market crash where the market
just goes Bingo boom straight to the
roof okay and it looks like hey guys
look how great the economy is doing look
how fantastic no no it's a lie it's a
lie the top 1% is killing it the rest
are getting destroyed watch this year
okay you know who would want some like
that guess who would want some like that
the top 1% yeah the top Point 1% like
yeah let's do it I got my money in the
market I'm going to be fine overnight
billionaires the level by the way look
at the months just go look at the months
actually look do you do you guys really
see this chart or no do you see what
this chart is one week mon guys it's
only a one-year chart mhm a year ago
where was their stock Venezuelan stock
market all the way at the at the top
ibbc it was at 10,000 a year ago it's at
63,000 the Market's gone up 630 per. in
less than a Tom do you see this chart in
yep in less than a year so I pray and
every American person and Realtors and
loan officers should be praying for
rates to stay the way they are for a
little longer
they should at least another year or two
it needs to stay at this rate then maybe
we level off at six FYI if unemployment
and things don't start moving you know
what Powell's going to do he has to go
up another quarter he has to go up
another quarter until that moves so
there's a bigger crisis that's Brewing
right now that most people are not
talking about it's called a reverse
market crash that's a scary s and let me
let me paint a a simple picture for you
okay step one the US government gave out
like 1.4 trilli trillion doll in
stimulus checks over the next 6 months
and we've talked about it on the show
credit card balances dropped to under
half a trillion dollars like 400 okay
then they went all the way back up to
900 at the same time the stock market
started running you want to know why you
know where all that you know where all
that credit card debt
is stuff people bought stuff stuff that
was sold by companies on the stock
market when they remember they were
saying well you know we were getting out
of coid and they know the markets way up
so I guess things are okay no no no we
printed 1.4 trillion dollar people paid
down their credit cards temporarily but
went back to their spending habits
restaurants were open able to travel and
they spent all the way up now to the
credit cards are on all-time high right
at a trillion dollars right now and all
that money it went to the stock market
how' it go to stock market the profits
of the companies that sold them all the
stuff do you see it so it runs to the
top that's part one and part two I wish
we could find it uh Rob this is this is
an issue that no one's talking about do
you guys follow how that works the money
runs to the bottom line of companies and
the pockets of the top 1% that own those
companies right now watch this you
remember the you just saw the chart
Venezuelan chart so go to Zillow and
find me any house in Fort Lauderdale
over $2 million and then P while he's
looking so that's going to separate like
the poverty like wow very bad in assria
yeah it's not a uh so that and you're
saying that that might happen
if Powell doesn't lower rates it's not
going to happen so the key is for him to
hold ground and not fall for any you
know phone calls that he's going to get
in the next nine months about changing
and lowering the rates so the market
moves because election is coming around
the corner SC the bot I don't know what
Pal's going to do but we will know to
give him proper credit by January of
2025 it's going to be a very hard next
15 months for pow and so so bad why look
at Venezuela is screwed then right what
what from what they just did their
future does not look brght why do you
think Venezuela finally mudo agreed to
come and negotiate with Biden to say
we're willing to sell oil to you and
we're willing to do a real public
election Fair even if I lose why would
Maduro agree for something like this
because his people are getting crushed
wow CR public embarrassment on what's
going on with Maduro and Venezuela right
now absolute public embarrassment Zillow
was taking the charts off Pat you know
the one I'm talking about they used to
have the charts in here scroll down yeah
they show it at the bottom the pricing
history and it goes up take a look does
this look like the Venezuelan stock
chart do you do you know something that
happen normal bro oh but by the way okay
if you guys want to talk about my house
let's talk about my house let's print
money okay Tom let's talk about my house
you know there was a record-breaking
sale in for laudel last week my realtor
sold it you know what the house sold for
$40 million in for laudel you know how
big is the land 04 Acres no way our
house is one and 1.2 1.3 Acres on the
water 810 ft of water Frontage one of
the biggest in all of four laudale we
bought the house for $2.4 million 2
years that's the house right there zoom
in that right there when is the date on
this can you zoom in so I can actually
give the real date beach front home just
that October 13 that's square right
there that's 0.4 Acres sold for $40
million what record-breaking by the way
our house that we bought for $2.4
million two years ago we closed on June
of 20
21 that house today is a $40 million
house mhm some say more okay now I may
sit there and say look at me I made this
money totally get it but guess what I
want people living close to my community
to have economic growth because if
people around you are having economic
growth your kids are in a safer
Community you're doing better you're not
worried about going shopping you're not
worried about what your wife is doing
you're not worried wored about what your
employees are doing you feel safer you
want the people in your community to be
doing better this is not good okay this
is very good MoneyWise yeah we made a
quick you know $20 million sale on the
house yes but if if if this continues
yeah it's going to be a very very
catastrophic issue when you see numbers
like this in one year go like this not
good it's not real it's fake it's purely
temporary by the way if this continues
your kids are going to live with you
forever and Vinnie and I are moving I'm
going to move in guys let's figure
something out your garage is bigger than
my apartment let's figure something out
to do something like that but no I mean
to be to be serious as as much as you
know we're having these types of
conversations kind of like what's going
to happen here I just hope Jerome Powell
and the establishment doesn't have dirt
on him from his past with a girl or with
a man or anything else or with money or
with his kids or anything to come to him
saying we have this on you you better
low the rat I hope that knock doesn't
happen to Jerome pal because if it does
it'll be temporary Market going up
celebration sugar it'll be catastrophic
for the next four years and what
speaking of pal 25 through 29 will be
catastrophic if he lowers the rates
speaking of pal it sounds like he's
doing something what I think is is
sensible right now he's come out and
saying we were expecting a Halloween
quarter point and then nothing to the
end of first quarter that was all the
FED Board of Governors were all talking
about the same things they look at
economic factors
well they don't want to Spook the market
another quarter point will spook the um
excuse me the equity markets the stock
markets they don't want to do that and
they also feel that right now inflation
has not gone down to the 2% Target they
wanted it to go down to it's it's it's
fighting hard to stay at like 4% give or
take so but what Pala said with the war
with uncertainty with a lot of things on
there I'm going to have a rate increased
pause and everyone on the FED board
seems to say they're going to go through
fourth quarter we're 1 month in the
fourth quarter now almost almost
November and through first quarter so
we're going to get to the end of first
quarter because the end of first quarter
is when you see how good Christmas was
how good was spending how good was all
that and take a look at how it's going
so what they're saying is I have given
you the remedy for your food poisoning
now you just have to kind of wait it out
you know what I mean you have to wait M
um and talking about waiting till the
end of the first quarter I think that's
sensible because I don't want volatility
what Pat is talking about is volatility
and it runs in two directions crash
crash haha on the rich you lost
everything yeah well so did your 401k so
did other things that are going on and
now it's near impossible for you bu that
you don't want it you know it's easy to
laugh at the risk what are they going to
do print another 1.4 trillion get ready
for $16 EG trust me trust me I'm telling
you like even right you know how many
people are coming right now saying Pat I
can get you 45 I can get you you know
how many strange phone calls we're not
selling a house bro but but the the the
the the the way to capitalize right now
would be to sell sit on cash rent two
years later come back buy kind of like
play that game we we but so and then the
the when you're talking to your
investment bankers you're talking to
your money managers it's like okay do
you go Equity do you not go Equity
you're talking to your peers okay if you
go Equity rates stay high unemployment
takes a hit recession comes next year
equities could get destroyed the next 12
months could get destroyed the next 12
months but if you're not in equities
Jerome pal lowers the rates and it goes
to whatever 4% 5% that was going to go
to 41,000 42,000 potentially within 12
to 18 months yes or no it'll go like
this skyrocketing okay so then your risk
is do I stay in the market do I not stay
in the market both ways it's risky today
there is no like path to look at because
we've never experienced
printing the kind of money that we did
going through a pandemic that we did
going through working from home
that we did going through two Wars that
we got going on one of them being so
unstable this is like there is no
financial analyst that knows the right
Investments to make today to whether
whatever is possible capable of
happening in the next 36 12 months so
what do you do you put a little
everywhere and you just have to do that
you have to do that you have to own a
little bit of gold okay this is not a
sponsorship I just tell you the
sponsorship is when I'm not doing a
sponsorship you have to own a little bit
of gold you have to look at what Bitcoin
did you know what Bitcoin hit have you
guys seen what Bitcoin just hit it's
right back up go to bitcoin where's
Bitcoin at right now yeah look at
Bitcoin like people like Bitcoin just
hit what 35,000 36
35,000 Bitcoin was like go go go go go
last year go last year yeah exactly look
at that hit 15,000 at 35,000 now and
look how it's going up you know Black
Rock just bought I think Black Rock just
introduce Bitcoin ETFs it's it's so
unpredictable today on what's going on
the danger sorry sorry sorry go ahead
you got all I want to say I'll put it
give it back to you just got to make
sure you're you know the concept of
diversification you know normally is not
something I would say all the time today
if you can predict the future and you're
willing to go fully risk which I'm
comfortable with then do that you're
taking a risk because you could have a
massive this or a massive this but if
you don't have that risk tolerance Your
solution right now is diversification
yep and printing money is dangerous and
Pat and I talked about and actually I
talked about I'll take credit for this I
thought the interest rates were going to
go all the way to 10% I said so and
they've made it to 8% eight and an e as
a matter of fact uh last week they were
actually eight and an eth even if you
had 670 credit right at je right now
they're about 7 half 7even through
quarter but there's something Pat said
that people don't remember um and you
you may not remember and I'm not trying
to insult the audience but you go back
back year ago when Pat said he was
really reacting we printed what percent
of the total money we had ever printed
in 6 months do you remember what the
number 40% 40% of the total money ever
printed in these United States now I say
print a lot of people get upset it's
issued because it's digital now too it's
not paper it's not all paper but we call
that money supply
40% that you did it in 6 months and and
look what you did to those housing
prices you did a Venezuela right now 10%
is now and so I I I I I say now people
say do you understand now you know it's
like the I just but I'm telling you Tom
I hope Powell doesn't break I hope
doesn't break because he needs to stay
it needs to stay like this and and it's
going to be
painful guys uh uh look you know not to
do a plug for my book but I'm talking to
Chris Williamson last week on his
podcast what a freaking in St of a guy
by the way this guy can you pull up his
picture Chris Williamson he's doing this
podcast and I pull up to this place I'm
like Sam where are we doing a podcast he
rented out this entire place that filled
with bookshelves absolutely sick sick uh
set that he had and we start talking and
we had a nice two and a half hour
conversation one of the biggest
podcasters in the in the world he's a
stat and we're talking about the book
that's coming out choose your enemies
wisely business planning for the
auditions for by the way uh it comes out
December 5th but I'm about to we're
about to relas release uh the
introduction at chapter one of the book
If you want to get a copy of the
introduction of chapter one way before
everybody else gets it text the word
book to 3103 41132 text the word book to
41132 in the next few days if you
purchase a copy or or the audible in the
book we're going to send you to chapter
one an introduction but just hang tight
you can place the order and then you'll
show me the receipt we'll send it to you
but text the word book to 3103 41132 let
me
continue a year and a half ago I'm
Consulting for is real estate guys
mortgage guys different companies not
necessarily company's name is mortgage
guys but guys that are in the mortgage
industry and I'm telling them listen you
have one too many Rolls-Royce you have
one too many Ferraris you have one too
many Chanel purses you have one too many
of these things you're not doing the
right thing it's too risky okay settle
down a little bit you're too loud you're
too arrogant right now you're too cocky
you think you know it all you think
you're untouchable you think you're not
going to be hit you're not paranoid
enough you're not concerned enough
you're not prepared enough you're not
anticipating what could happen the next
5 10 15 mes the crisis you're drinking
too much okay the the CEO of the company
the oldest company in America that's
1500 years old from Japan they said what
is the key to success and for you guys
to be Iran he says don't drink too much
what he was talking about is don't drink
your own success too much don't get too
like do you see what I'm consume with
your own success too much right so today
people are not prepared for for what's
about to come you know so for some
people that have been preparing for this
their wealth is going to go up 510 20 40
times because they've been preparing for
this but those that are not they're
going to get destroyed for the people
that are in the community that's said
how could you say this mortgage and be
like we need rates to get down I'm I'm
getting destroyed no you thought 3% was
going to be around for 20 years and your
business model is a failed model you
rely too much on 3% interest rates which
is fake we can't have it out at like
that so we have to go back to being
responsible but I think the next 6 12 18
months the whole concept of Team SPO SPO
SPO how much because you mention the
election p and pow and pressure and who
knows what the hell they're saying how
much of this situation which is a
volatile situation is going to affect
voting for the for the election all
those people in the middle this this is
a this is a very very volatile times
we're living in dude when Jamie Diamond
says this is the most dangerous times
we've lived in in the last few decades
not good why would he say that you you
your bank that you are the CEO to
transact $7 trillion it circulates every
single day s why would you say this may
be the most dangerous time the world has
seen in decades he you know what you
know what a job of a CEO of JP let me
just kind of give you an idea what his
job is every day he wakes up you know
what his job is this job yeah what can I
say or do to come my customers nerves
wow guess what you don't say something
like this yeah this may be the most
dangerous time the world has seen in
decad seeo Jamie Diamond then then you
got Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger
coming out talking about what they think
is going to happen real estate next year
or you got Ray doio saying World War I
likelihood is now 50% Michael bur why
would they say that yeah why would they
say that they don't want to market crash
their money's tied to all of this we
were warned that Trump was going to
cause all this stuff it didn't happen
under Trump and now it's all happening
and they're just finding other excuses
why and all that kind of and by the way
it's so interesting you're saying that
this is why billionaires like shamat are
saying I voted for
I voted for Biden but now I'm kind of
starting to ask myself maybe what Trump
did was a B+ maybe we need him back the
the approval rating you're saying with
Biden all 30% 30 31% 30 from Democrats
in some areas it's like they this is so
for people there's only so much American
people are going to take with a
president they voted for until it hits
their pocket in the economy they're like
uh uh uh no no it's time to switch uh it
may be a time that we may want switch as
America by the way check this out if
we're done with this part I want to go
to a couple stories of what's going on
with Israel okay so LA Times LA Times LA
Times talks about an article comes out
saying the left has really let us down
why many American Jews feel abandoned
this is a story that came out yesterday
okay many American Jews who
traditionally lean left have been
disappointed by the left's response to
the recent conflict some feel isolated
from the the political allies due to the
quick mobilization of support for the
Palestinian cause without condemning the
Hamas attack which resulted in the death
of many civilians including children
there's a divide among American Jews
regarding their stance on Israel and the
Israeli Palestine conflict while some
have long criticized israeli's policies
and want to see an end to the occupation
they also condemn violence and view the
situation with Nuance they emphasized
the need for a two-state solution and
call for ceasefire on the other hand
some far-left activists have expressed
views that Israel is a colonizing Force
justifying violence against it Tom
reaction to this article well you know
for the LA Times to be writing something
that means that there there is a real
story there uh you know but to me for
them to be writing something about the
about the left me in a negative way and
they're writing saying hey you know the
Jewish people in Southern California and
other places according to what we're
seeing um yeah they think that we've
kind of let them down on this whole is
quote Israel thing yeah yeah Israel
thing a war being being people being
killed in their beds you know is an
Israel thing uh and it kind of I'm
shocked but not shocked because is it in
the face of reality are are even the
liberal news media starting to write
little things and that's what I'm
thinking is there a glimmer of of Hope
from journalism and I don't really think
there's a glimmer of hope for jism but I
I get that feeling when I look at it I'm
like wow you know is is it possible I
think the colonizing that word they keep
using and I was watching a really
interesting uh video and it was talking
about which religion is older who was in
the land first so it's uh do you guys
know how old Judaism is average there's
people argue about it all the time how
old judism shoot I mean because the
syrians were
around what would you say couple
thousand years Yep they're saying 1800
BC so 2400 years l Christianity came
after that Islam came after that it's
the newest of them 700 AD so 2500 years
older than than um Islam and so history
lesson so we're all complaining about
1948 that's when Israel you know took
the land their colonizers before that it
was the British Mandate of Palestine
before that the Ottoman Empire before
that the sultan nightes then the
Byzantine Roman Empire Babylon Assyrian
Empire then the two kingdoms of Israel
and Judah the 12 tribes of Israel and
the Canaanite City kingdoms so it's not
who was here first from 1948 if you want
to go back to who was here first you got
to go back at least 3 4,000 years and I
mean and and Tom when you say like well
Pat the the the the left let them down I
mean who would have thought like you see
what's happening where they're having
all these Pro Hamas uh protests where
they're
insurreccion Pat you what what happened
in Israel horrible okay you could still
pray and and hope that the children and
the innocent lives in Palestine are okay
but when you are pro- Hamas which is a
terrorist organ I don't give a what
the hell you say that's where you're
losing people so the left is like wait a
minute we were all cool and you were on
our sides but you have this happen by
the way that these PE I want to know if
any one of these people okay that are
promoting and stearing for a terrorist
organization are going to get the FBI to
follow all of them home and and arrest
them and even their people that didn't
show up and they're going to treat them
they're going to do 20 years in prison
so I I could I could see a pack cuz it's
like I this it's a really horrible
situation I'm happy that it woke these
people up because they like oh my God
this is how the the the left doesn't
give a outside outside of Rashida
talib's office is the gay flag and the
Palestine flag black lives matter flag
one flag is missing the United States
flag yeah we're and Pat if if you don't
mind me uh shifting to this and I know
we spoked about it with Charlie Kirk and
stuff you know what what still hasn't
been answered Pat which nobody's talking
about and John Kirby said and I quote
now is not the time has there been any
update on on how everybody came in and
even worse than the the them coming in
for 6 hours Pat let me explain something
to you what look think about this it's
10:00 right now can you imagine till 400
p.m. people are attacking this one
little building Pat and nobody responds
zero IDF zero soldiers nothing happens
and that's still not being talked to
because now it's almost like nope nobody
cares because Hamas is is is hiding
behind kids okay we have killed we I'm
sorry Israel has bombed and killed three
times the amount of people that were
killed in Israel on on their initial
attack and by the way how many you know
how many innocent women and children it
is it's astronomically more than Hamas
because what are the Hamas numbers they
don't know CU there only 40 thou 40,000
Hamas scattered in there they are
bombing and taking down like huge
apartment buildings with women and
children Pat and I talked about this on
Brandon's episode I was watching like
the hospital that was bombed and nobody
you're not seeing this on CNN or
anything a mother laying there white
pale face she's bleeding out and her
three-year-old kid is standing there
shaking with shell shock and you don't
see that nobody's talking about those
kids you know what I mean nobody you're
not hearing any of that it's just hey we
got to wipe out Hamas what about like
the grandmothers the children the it's
insane and it's like at what point are
we going to say okay guys time out
another option you know what pets
another option send in some special
forces okay enough okay you killed a lot
okay send it yeah it's going to be
dangerous for the Special Forces but I
mean how long is it going to go po mind
you Pat the ground Invasion hasn't
happened yet they're just bombing
everywhere wait till it the the the the
worst is still to come and it's like
guys at the end of the day I get it it
was a it was a tragedy travesty we have
to figure out why to prevent it and when
people are like you're not supporting
Israel no no you don't what you know
what Israel should just do right now
beef up your security so it doesn't
happen again stop the the the insane
bombing and sending Special Forces to
find these people that are hiding behind
and using uh women and children as
Shield it's like enough enough is enough
when people like peace in the Middle
East we're Middle Eastern it it ain't
going to happen I'm sorry it's too much
when religion is involved and religion
is the number one cause of death in this
in the history of mankind it's like
enough is enough how many Innocents are
going to die so a couple things there
the first thing is when they're using
human Shields and you're you're trying
to go in there you there's a few things
going on um
Tom let me just give you my thoughts
okay so let me let's let's kind of talk
about what you just said try to be
careful um let's let's kind of talk
about what you you just said so for me
as a leader anytime we have to make a
big decision I try to look at it from
the emotional and The Logical side it's
very hard to do very very hard to do
it's not easy to do uh there's a book
called five Temptations of a CEO by
Patrick lenon I recommend it all the
time to business owner it's a great book
to read five Temptations He talks about
uh one of them is five Temptations of a
SE I'll read the five there go
Temptation number one is strategy for
overcoming focus on results uh so
Temptation number one is status you want
to be pop you know oh my God my status
I'm a CEO number two popularity um so
you want people to like you so number
one is my status I'm I'm famous I'm a
CEO I'm a president I'm this number two
is popularity number three is certainty
so sometimes because you want a certain
decision you don't necessarily make a
decision then it's for uh Force Harmony
and invulnerability okay so these are
temptations that cosos and leaders fall
for let's let's kind of keep this up
there and don't take this away so I can
look at it so as a president right now
you know you have to make a you know
decision that uh is not necessarily
going to be maybe the most popular
decision so and some of the decisions
you have to make is not going to be
public you got to get inventory all the
information from both sides and kind of
make a decision for yourself
one emotionally both sides are are using
videos to get you and I
emotional and give permission for
reaction okay I'm a father of four I
watched all the videos with kids it gets
sent to me all the time okay both from
the Muslim side from the Palestine side
from the Israeli side you can keep
sending me those videos I watch them
it's not easy to watch they're
heartbreaking to watch and remember this
is coming from a guy that lived in Iran
10 years and witnessed war and it was
terrible I couldn't stand it I saw a lot
of weird things as a kid I should have
never seen no kid should ever see what
but you know everybody's dealt with
different cards you can't complain about
it you got to kind of figure out the
life I could grow up and say oh it's
unfair what happened to me yeah it's
unfair I get it it wasn't cool I don't
want to see it happen to my kids but it
happened so emotionally very painful
it's very hard right now to avoid being
tempted to join the jump to conclusion
Community everybody's to jump into
conclusion uh the more we jump to
conclusion the more we increase the
chance of World War III the more we jump
to conclusion the more we increase the
chances of division the more we jump to
conclusion the more we can be controlled
the more we jump to conclusion the more
slave we are to our emotions your job as
a leader to try to minimize as much of
your decisions being made emotionally
and try to make it logically not easy to
do very hard let's look at logically
okay um let's say Israel succeeds and is
able to kill 40,000 Hamas members cuz
they got 40,000 let's say they succeed
okay let's say you do it okay cool you
got got rid of
40,000 um is the residual effect of that
done are they done done so is that it
that's it you will never have promin a
middle east ever again now you just
pissed off Hezbollah they got 150,000
okay you're now going to have someone's
kids cousin that's going to seek
Vengeance that's seven years old that's
going to be fed this story of what they
did to his mom dad brother sister
everybody that's going to seek vengeance
for 10 years and it's going to be 10
times uglier than what you had today
it's not going to follow it's not going
to come it's not going to slow down it's
not going to slow down at all Iran is
just looking for an opportunity to go to
war us uh Israel is looking for an
opportunity to have permission to bomb
Gaza they're just looking for an
opportunity they're all looking for OPP
opportunities right now and meanwhile a
bunch of people are in the middle of it
okay on how to handle this um we are
sending $100 million Biden just approved
$100 million to go to Gaza okay to go
send to Palestine which the majority is
going to Ukraine you know that right the
majority of that package is going to
Ukraine and they're going to get and the
money that ends up going to Palestine
who knows if Hamas and the the group's
going to have that money go to its
people okay number two that if you look
it logically as much as like what do you
do with a person that's in a marriage
that they're getting abused over and
over again by the person they're married
to what can you do about that person
honestly so you got a woman that's
married to a man who hits her with a
stick absolutely Abus her in the
community and she still loves him and
she still supports him what can you do
to her to change her mind do you know
58% of Palestinians in Gaza support
Hamas 42% of uh Palestinians in West
Bank support Hamas you think you're
going to change I'm sorry no you're not
you're getting what you're getting you
58% so they're using the people as human
Shields there's this uh meme I don't
know if you've seen this meme where half
of it is showing Israeli in the front
with the kids in the back and they're
protecting the kids and the other meme
is what you know Hamas people using the
kids in the front as a shield to not
have Israel attack him right okay it's a
very powerful meme true or not true it's
a powerful meme on the story that it's
telling right okay fantastic that's uh
the gamesmanship that both sides want to
play to rap you know get our emotions
right there that's the story One is
using a wife and a woman and the kids
and the other one is hiding right the
bottom left one too yeah there's so many
of these that you can look at right this
is divisive if it's true if it's not
true say it's true okay these are not
same types of people as us Hamas is not
the same type of people as us if a
person is still loyal to the person
that's betraying them there's nothing
you can do about it if Palestinians are
supportive to that and they're
supporting the Hamas way of leadership
look you get what you ask for this is
yours so let's look at the residual
effects worldwide do you want people
from Palestine to move to for Lael do
you do you want uh Palestinians to move
here report came out here's a report
that just came out um and it's coming to
us uh from fed fed warns that Hamas
Hezbollah could be crossing the southern
border can you pull up this article Rob
head the fed this is not like a
hypothetical this is fed yeah it's not a
news not a news organiz if they're
warning do you think they're warning
because it already happened or do you
think they can predict the future it's
already happening it's already happening
so they're saying that hey this is Poss
Rob just search it don't worry about
looking for it that you have up there
just type in fed warns that Hamas could
be crossing the southern border and
you'll see it okay so why should you be
concerned about this because logically
your number one priority should be the
community you live in the country you if
you're German you should be worried
about the city you live in in Germany
your country German if you live in
Palestine your warriors should be what
Palestinians if you're in Gaza Strip if
you're if you're Israeli your Warrior
should be what Israel first if you're
Egypt it should be what Egypt first
first if your Jordan should be what
Jordan first Iranian people are going to
be what Iran first what what's America
going to be America first and that's
what you should be thinking about so if
the FED is telling us you warning that
members of Hamas Palestinian Islamic
Jihad p and Hezbollah are crossing
aborted through S according to internal
20 October 20 memo exclusively plained
by the daily col news Foundation that
San Diego field office Intelligence
Division of Customs and Border senent
memal warning that due to the war
between Israel and Hamas there could be
Encounters of charti individuals who are
seeking to travel to or from Middle East
via transit across the southern border
okay guess
what you can sit there and and
moan from both
sides and if you want those guys to be
safer they have to find another country
do you want to take them do you want to
have them come here they're chanting
death to America death to Israel from in
the Cradle yeah and and the the
elimination of Jews elimin and these are
in US genocide this is in protesting M
okay um so yeah no to me I I I I have
zero tolerance for Hamas Hezbollah Isis
uh any of these organizations what
they're doing I have zero trust in them
uh on what they have going on if your
community Palestinians 58% supports
Hamas and 42% at West Bank supports
Hamas what do you want to do change your
minds what are we supposed to do you sit
there and say you don't understand how
bad your husband is no she knows and she
still want to be married to him so
to cut you off so cuz now and you know
I've I've learned a lot in my life to
just stop and say okay why why are the
people of Palestine uh supporting Hamas
so much why are Americans American
Palestinians as well cheer I I'm still
boggled is it pat because they don't
have anybody else that is actually I
mean it sucks it's a Hamas is a
terrorist organization is it because
that's all they have that is actually
fighting
that's all they have that is one of the
reasons so it sucks but I mean what but
but but okay so what's the solution
that's what I'm saying I but what's the
solution so for example look at it from
this standpoint
okay we don't mind people coming to
America legally come to America legally
I came to America legally we had we
asked for green card in 1984 we didn't
get it till 1990 I didn't come here till
November 29 we would have come to
America in 84 we couldn't come to
America in 84 waited six years went
through a bunch of Wars eventually D
went to Germany lived at a refuge Camp
finally came your legally that sucked
for 6 years we would have gladly I would
have been so much ahead if I would have
come here in 1984 in a different kind of
a way we would have already made the
proper adjustments school all this other
stuff no we came in November 20 1990
okay
so how many bad apples does it take to
cause one of your kids to pick up a bad
habit how many seven eight 14 Tom how
many how many bad apples do you worry
about in a class if you're s if if your
daughter has five friends how many of
those five friends does it cause your
daughter to potentially pick up bad
habits one one okay how many bad apples
does it take to take as refugees to come
here to the
states that's that's going to cause
Mayhem later on how many bad apples is
it 50 is it 100 is it a th000 is it 800
or is it one it's one all you need is
one it's not going to take that many mhm
you know we're not looking for a well
what if we take a m but these are good
people I understand they're good people
totally get it I'm closing the border
for one straight year flat out we're
building walls on top of walls is what
we're doing Southern border walls on top
of walls for you to have to make up you
made up after one wall guess what it's
like a video game now you got to go
level two wall now you're got to go a
level three wall but you got walls on
top of walls until you make it over why
this is real and unfortunately the
problem of a bad apple when it befriends
a kid I remember a guy became friends
with one of my best friends and we were
in eighth grade okay 8 nth grade I'm in
Wilson Junior High School ninth
grade this guy introduced him to
cigarettes then alcohol then weed then
prostitutes then it led to Special K
ecstasy cocaine heroin vicadin every
drug every drug pretty much every drug
possible so from
1994 eventually he paid the price in
2005 when he died wow and I got the
phone call okay 11 years later is what
it took a bad apple doesn't take one
month to identify not 6 months not 12
months it takes a decade or two so as a
leader unfortunately everybody's trying
to get elected for policies that benefit
us today no one's trying to get elected
based on policies that protects a
country for 20 30 40 years from now uh
did you watch what what the Holland uh
is it Holland Hungary uh uh prime
minister or the Holland prime minister
which one is it it was a Poland Poland
it's one of them he was like I'm not
letting nobody come in here let me let
me show this Poland I think it was
Poland so I don't know if you guys have
ever seen this how he straight up says
it and it's so powerful the way this guy
says it let me here it is I found it
here's a clip prop I'm going to text it
to you uh uh oh let me see how long this
one is yeah this is the one I just found
this watch this look at the he answers
this and guess what guess who loves what
he had to say okay guess who loves what
he had to say the people that are part
of his country okay the people that are
part of his country um right pull up
this clip uh uh
uh if you can pull out this clip I just
sent you watch the reaction to this
would you like a leader like this would
you like by the way your answer to this
question reveals who you are watch this
if I like a leader like this guy
would you like a leader like this on
where his priorities are go and play the
clip
M okay let me put that point cannot
leave it let me put that point to Mr
tski because let me just ask Mr tski how
many refugees has Poland
taken zero and you're proud of that if
you are asking me if you're if you are
asking me about Muslim uh Muslims
illegal immigration none not even one
will come to Poland not even one if it's
illegal we we took over 2 million
ukrainians who are working who are
peaceful in Poland we will not receive
even one Muslim because this is what we
promised but I asked not about illegal
immigrants I asked about refugees and
Jean CLA junker the commission President
says that you're racist you sound proud
of the fact that you haven't taken any
refugees of course because this is what
our people expecting from our government
number one this is why our government
was elected this is why Poland is so
safe this is the the the reason why we
had not even uh one terrorist attack
look at the streets in Poland and we can
be called populists nationalists racists
I don't care I care about my family and
about my country that's right this is 5
years ago five years ago this is what
the president of the United States needs
to say today well Trump he tried to say
that well Trump tried to what happened
you racist you scumbag by the way it's
totally fine they're supposed to say it
yeah that's totally fine supposed to say
it now you got so much data to show
what's happened the last four years the
right president gets up and says my
number one job is the people of the
United States of America number two is
the Allies who love us and are good to
us who respect us number three is
everybody else but number one is is the
people here number two our allies that
are good to us number three is everybody
else that's your job nothing more
nothing less but who we're fighting is
the left the left looks at the whole map
and goes well who's the losers that's
who I side with they don't look at the
whole picture they just who's the loser
today that's who I'm on the but you said
and you said something Pat last week
that like kind of it woke me up and gave
me a little chilling effect about how it
ain't going to happen now it's not going
to happen it could you could be eight
years from now and I'm being de here you
got I got goosebumps when you said it
you're going to be chilling Americans
like everything's good and then boom's
going happen something because you know
I already think Pat the damage has been
done they've opened the and I and again
we keep going back to the Border it's
still to right now today wide open there
is it's come on everybody come in and
it's not by accident I'm tired of people
out there going you heartless you don't
care that's what America and the statue
statue of liberty is no no no no no no
it's and but that's what I'm scared
about is it's too late it's hey it's
it's gonna happen it's inevitable so
just be prepared because it's coming
even the 911 hijackers were here from
January of 2000 and the attack didn't
occur for another 18 19 months later so
chilling so gu by the way just just
everybody I can entertain two ideas I
still don't know why the hell you know I
think Netanyahu if you ask me I think he
needed a a permission to go attack
Palestine I really think he needed
permission to go after what he's doing
with Hamas I think that's what he was
doing but at the same time I also can
pose the question and say if they're so
peaceful why isn't Jordan and Egypt
taking Palestinians why is why are they
not aggressively saying come over here
why that's a valid question as well that
you have to answer so yeah and FYI there
was a comedian that was on uh uh Pierce
Morgan the video that went viral on good
looking guy very well spoken guy uh by
the way his mother-in-law lives in Gaza
right so B there is no benefit to
debating Kim MH do you know why because
it's 100% emotions tied who does he love
more than his wife and his kids nobody
what you're not going to win nope there
is nobody winning anything you say that
defers what he believes in you're
offending his wife and his kids there is
no winning a debate like that so this
wasn't like hey who's right who's wrong
there is no purpose to debating
something like that for me to prove that
what you're personally going through cuz
your in-laws couldn't make it to your
wedding is because of what they were
going through that's permanent damage
it's gone you're not going to change
somebody's True Believer or mentality
that's permanent marks that's going to
stay so when you're seeing some of this
stuff like that's right and that's right
and what about this and what about that
and what about this yeah I I am
encouraging a new party to get started
you know what the party is the party of
the skeptical the party of the avoiding
jumping into the conclusion community
that party that's willing to question
things instead of saying not right now
not right now not right now now listen
my job is a question I'm a C I'm not a
journalist I'm a guy that wants to learn
and get better and we're going to keep
asking the questions until we learn
something something that's what we're
going to be doing as a podcast show that
we have called You're called pbd podcast
until we get some kind of Intel back
anyways uh so so that's some of the
stories we covered with this let me get
to the next story here uh uh George
Floyd uh Vinnie what what what just
happened I saw an article that came out
we were talking about this here with Rob
yesterday with different guys what's
going on with the George Floyd story
that just came out so I feel like Tom
because I took a page out of his
actually I took three pages so it might
take a little bit but just bear with me
I love you Tom prepared I'm prepared bro
what do you want do so it actually turns
out Pat that Derrick schin didn't kill
George Floyd it was either China or
Mexico because new court documents
reveal that George Floyd died of a
fentanyl overdose and not from xixi or
strangulation okay and the reason Pat
this is random that the court documents
came to light is because Amy Sweezy
she's a former henpen County Minnesota
prosecutor who was suing her employer
alleging she was a sex victim of
discrimination and retaliation and PS
hennipin County is entirely Democrat so
we all know Democrats don't always find
it necessary to follow their loudly
stated rules anyway so the reason her
lawsuit matters is cuz guess where
George Floyd died henpen County and
depositions in her case make it clear
that the prosecutors always knew that
Derek shavin and the other three police
did not kill George Floyd So Pat she's
pissed she's suing and she's bringing
everybody down with her so during her
deposition she discussed a conversation
she had uh after George Floyd's death
when uh the henip County Medical
Examiner Dr Andrew Baker uh spoke about
the autopsy and this is what she said
she said and I quote I called Dr B uh Dr
Baker early that morning to tell him
about the case and ask him if he would
perform the autopsy he called me later
that day on Tuesday and he told me that
there were no medical findings that
showed any injury to the vital
structures of Mr Floyd's neck there were
no medical indications of aixia or
strangulation that's right uh he said to
me Amy what happens when the actual
evidence doesn't match up with the
public narrative that everyone's already
decided on and he said this is the kind
of case that ends career so the other
depositions from other attorneys in the
office show that the decision to
prosecute chovin was purely political
Pat and the prosecutors feared the mob
and they were happy uh to go after the
police so uh now I know this going to
piss people off Pat but like remember
Sor and all these guys said never let a
crisis go to waste ever right so uh this
going to piss people off that need that
we all saw and you know horrible
obviously it looked really bad he was
screaming it did not kill him it's
period and Pat I have Rob has the the
corers report zoom in a little bit more
yeah it's a little bit blurry but this
is the corers report no lifethreatening
injuries identify no facial or oral or
conjunctive Pat nothing to his face
nothing to his neck and if you look
towards the bottom rock it B is
important item B go to the end of back
up back up back up back up that word in
Item B
Lauren let me translate that exactly
that's the throat no injuries to his
throat oh throat cred or throat no l no
no no like when when when something like
they can tell if it was because if
something's broken even if there too
much
pressure so they also found fat uh
fentanyl look look look the bottom right
there 11 NG ml P less than one ml the
nlme is is a high dose okay 17 ngml is
lethal you're dead he had pretty much
enough to kill him and then he had nor
fetanyl at 5 point 6 ml he had a bunch
of other stuff P look at number four
must have been his birthday meth yeah
methan fenine all this type uh all this
stuff in there p and it's like let's not
forget okay let's let's take a step back
okay the cops were called to the scene
because he was trying to use a fake $20
bill to buy cigarettes right when they
showed up he was resisting arrest body
cam footage shows him Pat eight dropping
a a white bag putting picking it back up
and then inside the uh he was resisting
arrest he's putting in his mouth they
saw like about apparently it was you
know 2 milligrams of fentanyl uh add add
to that he had coid severe heart disease
combined with stress yes the situation
caffeine Pat the situation yeah with oh
my God resisting and all that all that
stuff and again stuff people don't want
to hear let's let's let's not forget who
this guy was right uh you couldn't say
this in 2019 but I can say whatever the
hell I want now cuz nobody's afraid of
the mob he was a shitty a shitty citizen
a shitty human being arrested nine times
for theft drugs one of those times was a
home invasion Pat he came in with Five
Guys they knocked on the door posing as
a water company Mass they came in they
grabbed the pregnant black chick he held
a gun to her stomach where her baby was
in her toddler was in the house he hit
her in the head with a gun invaded the
robbed everything and left the house
okay now this goes down to why Pat why
did the government why the media harp on
this situation and make it you know made
him look like a martyr and everything
and I'll tell you why his death was a
flasho for Democrats uh racist Firestorm
which was used to destroy American
cities how many years did this country
burn Pat Uh and and to game an election
for Trump think about that that happened
Pat George Soros money BLM everybody's
racist burn this down the streets
antifa and George and the BLM movement
not only uh how many hundreds of
millions of dollars it was all still
they pushed it to to further the agenda
Pat and I know I've said this before my
one of my favorite shows I think you
said it's the only one that you've
watched this episode was in House of
Cards uh season 1 episode 6 where
there's a teacher strike right Pat and
so uh Frank Underwood's trying to fight
with the the union he sits there and
he's monitoring the uh scanner police
scanner and as soon as a a a girl dies
is in a car accident he rushes to the
media Pat everybody's there the White
House is there and he's like this girl
died because she wasn't in school
because of the strike so they take these
moments Pat and they blow it up and
racist and racist and racist I'm sorry
everybody that wasn't the case Pat so
now that the facts are out I want to ask
you guys do they release this guy
Patrick do they say okay now now that
this is out and it's it's this is
substantial evidence there it's
completely clear vandalism and looting
that occurred between May 26th and June
8th caused approximately one to2 billion
and Ure damages nationally the highest
recorded damage from civil disorder in
US history and surpassing the records
set at the 1992 LA
riots yeah so when you by the way I
don't know if you know I'm still
supportive of the guy sitting on his
neck for8 minutes whatever the time you
don't need to do that too there was
people also with their phones out they
could have gone in there done something
about it or just said stop or you know
pick him up put him in the car but
everybody was also recording so there
there's the the guilt could be but I by
the way I love citizen journalism I
think accountability at the highest
level would go on live is fantastic but
some people could say hey officer you
know do something about it to at least
pick him up put him in and I agree I
agree Pat I agree I agree with obviously
and by the way the Optics it look
horrible I'm I don't by the way like
again I was an MP you're not like doing
that for that long milary police but
yeah the guy but why were the cops there
the dude if you weren't a a shitty guy
counterfeit drugs he ODed prior to this
situation for sure oh for sure no no
we're not talking about that for sure
but facts look you you got no you gave
facts today based on what the report is
but here's the part I mean you know what
was a guy's name that said this who's
got a brother Rah Emanuel Ram Emanuel
said this way you know you never let a
crisis go away all these guys they they
used it and by the way it's been used
for very very long time this is why I
believe we need to create a new
community called the anti- jump to
conclusion Community we need a anti-
jump to conclusion party anti- jump to
conclusion mindset everybody is jumping
to conclusion right now and capitalizing
off the opportunity and those people
need to be held accountable the people
that are instigating that's leading to
stuff like this should also be held
accountable if you went against them
then you were called a racist you lost
your job there was a high school
wrestling coach that showed if you put
his knee on his wrestling uh you know
students shoulder for up to 10 minutes
it didn't stop anything he lost his job
the kid got you know ridiculed and we
all know this from UFC 20 minutes he's
saying I can't breathe I can't breathe
how long in a UFC match do you put in a
choke before they tap out or end the
match how many how many seconds oh oh
is seconds 10 seconds 15 they're
going like this you don't do 20 minutes
I can't breathe that was just a a
psychological operative just to destroy
our country P so I like I like your part
of the non we call it the nonp conclusus
part conclusion NJ non to conclusion
Community people are jumping to
conclusion a lot and it's and it's
hurting a lot of people okay so uh Tom
women 25 years old Sparks Fierce debate
after Brandon College as scam this is a
Daily Mail
story uh we wrote a book on this a
couple years ago Tom uh let me go to
what is it what page page here we go
okay women 25 years old Sparks spars
debate after branding College as a scam
October 23rd stored from Daily Mail
college graduate Allison Johnson 25
years old IGN at a f debate on TiK ToK
by denouncing college s scam revealing
her $80,000 debt and her struggle to
secure a well-paying job in her field in
her video which garnered over 539,000
views she Express her frustration
stating I have I have my literal
business marketing degree which put me
$80,000 in debt and I make more serving
Sushi roles Allison emphasized her
difficulty in updating marketing jobs
where entry-level positions offered
meager salaries compared to her current
waitressing job she questioned the value
of her education raising doubts about
what her investment in college was
worthwhile whether I'm he I'm headed to
my serving job and I'm fing hating it
meanwhile I make more money serving than
I would at an entry-level marketing job
she liment to Tom thoughts on this so
there's there's three things going on
here the first thing is she doesn't
really like her current job but she's
keeping it to survive because she can
make money on it the second thing is
she's actually a college graduate she
actually got through there and the third
thing is
$80,000 for in debt she's basically
bought a giant Ford F-150 crew cab
pickup all tricked out that's basically
folks as if she had walked out of
college and bought that kind of debt so
what's going on here is she has a point
the point she has is I can't find a job
that I can afford to go to and because
of my student debt because of what got
on top of that and you know I can make
more waiting tables well you know what
you can do that on day one right it's
called you where are you going to be in
10 years with that marketing degree
you're not going to be in the same spot
you're going to put it to work and by
the way you have a marketing degree
you're doing pretty good on social media
pleading your case here so you're you're
marketing yourself pretty well but this
is this is this is a truth the tuitions
are up at crazy levels you go there to
be indoctrinated you end up 80,000 in
debt and now you're at a job you really
don't like cuz you just have to make
ends me but let me tell you those lines
are going to cross and that's what she's
not pointing out and that's not what all
the the the liberal sympathizers are are
not seeing is that if she puts her
shoulder to the load in that career
she's going to be making far more than
waiting tables so you don't like what
you can make on day one walking out with
your marketing degree With No E no
experience but you're going to make
experience and that the lines are going
to cross here the real issue is you
knowingly accepted the fact where you
selected where to go to college that
you're going to be $80,000 in debt and
tuition is not tuition is not cheap and
so she makes a point here about the I
don't think it's about the student loan
crisis the point is is the tuition
crisis tuition inflation over the last
30 years which is ridiculous compared to
just normal CPI Consumer Price Index and
normal and so I think she has a point
about that but she's not paying
attention that if you just put some work
in it you can get there Kavon can I ask
you a question sure to can I do a quick
case study with Kavon case study here
Kon you wanted to be uh a comedian you
discovered you had some talent for it
what were you paid when they would give
you what do they call fives you can do a
five minute like in between two big
comedians what were you paid for that
french fries if I was lucky seriously oh
have a have a burger and french fries
bur hey who said you have a burger no we
got we had a drink we had they'd give us
a drink or like a bottle of water or
Coca-Cola right you get a little ticket
I want my Coca-Cola yeah that's it we we
weren't p and when you're finally how
long did you do that probably for about
a year and a half two years okay and
when you finally got paid for maybe a
five minute at a better part of the
night you're going to go right between
our two guys at 9 and 10:00 I'm giving
you a prime five o' Prime five minutes
how much was that 20 bucks and I would
let them pile up so I go get six checks
I'm like to feel better yeah yeah
exactly now then two years later what
were you doing okay so two years after
that probably $100 to $300 a show there
you go yeah so you went from 10 bucks to
100 bucks french fries to to 100 bucks
right that's a that's a big difference
yeah yeah well she's not going to go
there but the point is when you walk
into something with with education you
have to add to that experience would you
hire this person if she's one of the
ones right now like she appli she she
sends a resume and Rob sees it I'm the
girl that you guys talk about on the
podcast would you hire her with the
answer that she
gave I I give her a zoom I'd give her
absolutely give her a zoom interview
I'll tell you I'll give her a great
interview and I'll really Probe on some
things and I would give her a serious
look mhm you'd give her a serious look
on what she's saying okay all right um
you know I'd also ask her what she's
thinking with the 80,000 student loans
and how did it end up there I want to
look at judgment I want to look at a lot
of things but that goes quick these days
what goes quick these days the uh the
tuitions are out of control and they're
getting Government funding and they're
doing the rock climbing wall on opening
week they're putting on concerts at the
school and then they're doing a sex toy
gay pride week so all this stuff cost
money and then all that money is being
spent and then these people are coming
out with a degree that doesn't help them
in the real world so then they're
getting mad now Trump you was labeled as
a scam when people weren't making the
money they thought they were they sued
Trump you and the left chears about it
but now the left is is complaining
they're not getting any value out of
their education well then sue the
university and say give me a degree that
can work for me if I'm willing to work
and by the way during an interview it
may turn out that this is just an angry
liberal person that's just spouting off
and is not employable yeah we don't want
that let me let me do this last story
before we wrap up we got a couple
minutes left here uh Vinnie new details
in death of Obama's personal chef raises
questions PJ media October 22nd new
information obtained through an foia
request reveals that former president
Barack Obama was on the scene shortly
after his personal chef tafari Campbell
when missing initially they told us
they're not there right and uh um when
missing n was later found drowned
contradicting initial reports of the
Obama's absence Jesse Waters reported
according to the reports Obama was on
the scene shortly after Campbell went
missing shedding lights on the
previously undisclosed detail the
Massachusetts State Police revealed a
report with redactions inditing that wow
this is from the state police damn State
pleas inditing that redacting that
Barack Obama arrived at the emergency
response scene via motorcade and an
unarmed female staff for attempted to
rescue Campbell when he fell off his
board this information raises questions
about the extent of Obama's involvement
in the incident kind of strange it's
like what do you mean kind of strange
it's like the lies from the jump and
then Pat I'm telling you right now like
why did it take so long to find out and
I'm sick and tired of all the lies and
all the unanswered questions and then
when people ask why we're The Crazy Ones
okay and it's like something of that
magnitude you have to be open and honest
and the reports Pat some of them said
that he showed up on the scene via
motorcade a short time later a cold wet
woman who was a witness arrived the next
morning she was interviewed in Barack
Obama's residence there with him present
it's kind of it's kind of sus uh Raa
also States uh unnamed staffer yeah she
jumped in the water to try to get him
out still 8T of water and he's a he's a
a nasty swimmer uh he disappeared we
also know that secret service has
surveillance footage of Campbell from
Obama's compound moments before he enter
the water okay wow can we see that
footage and what what are you what are
you redacting that the public can't see
about this guy it's like it's always a
situation and you know what Pat
something of this magnitude I don't
believe you when it comes to when when
that type of stuff happens and you lie
and you don't answer us I don't I don't
believe that you weren't in a limousine
smoking crack and hooking up with a guy
named Larry Sinclair it's like you don't
address it you don't talk about it
everything is is is masked under this
cloak of of secrecy it's like bro when
like yeah it's they living their own
lives but how many people have to die
how many weird circumstances P how many
people have to commit suicide how many
it's always like an Allure like oh my
God what a what a crazy what do you
think it was though what do you think it
would like oh I'm I'm happy you asked
that got my I got my notes like Steve
Schmidt was from wait wait he was paddle
boarding bumped into the grassy no fell
off the paddle board Patrick I'm so
happy because you I I I was going to
look over it there were rumors
circulating that tafari was writing a
book about the Obamas they caught wind
of it and they were like no it's not
going to happen uh I wonder what kind of
dirt like who's given the source who who
sourc it's it just I this is what I've
heard because guess what I haven't heard
anything else that this is randomly
happening but can you imagine what
chapter one of that book like would be I
saw the schlong something something
weird it's just Pat it's just here's the
thing can you just be up front honest
with us yeah here's the footage look at
him he was swimming God forbid the poor
guy passed away why why the question
super strange super strange that this is
taking place who knows why they're
holding it back the fact that the story
changes and this is a president not a
random person talking about a you know
person but a president that's going by
the way you know you know what Matt
Gates just did Matt Gates said we can
agree for who's going to be the speaker
of the house as long as they whoever
that gets elected 100% agrees that
they're going to release a 100% of the
footage from January 6th oh really
that's what he's asking for whoever
wants to be the speaker of the house and
they're going to need his vote oh wow
100% of the January 6 video he wants to
be released anyways uh gang uh uh uh
really enjoy today's podcast Rob we got
another podcast coming up on uh Thursday
Thursday with anak asarian from The
Young Turks fantastic anak kasparan will
be here from The Young Turks we'll see
what angle she's going to have with all
the stuff that's going on having said
that one more time for those of you guys
that want to get the introduction in
chapter one of choose your enemies
wisely that's coming out December 5th
we're about to launch the intro in
chapter 1 text award book to 31034 11132
again text award book to 310 340 11132
take care everybody bye- bye
bye-bye